You make a multi-map that is your sort function, and then you call isSorted, and then you call sort, right? There are only three ideas there. And the number of ideas in the problem is how I measure the triviality in a sense. It feels like the things that I love about C++ and Haskell are just everything is there in BQn like and more welcome to adsp the podcast episode 215 recorded on december 16th 2024 my name is connor and today with my co-host Ben we continue part two of our chat comparing different approaches to solving Avent of Code problems. In today's discussion we talk about C++, BQN and more. So the question behind this observation is like what is BQN for in your opinion? What is it good at? What does it solve well?
你写一个多重映射作为你的排序函数，然后调用 isSorted，再调用 sort，对吧？这里面只有三个概念。而问题中概念的数量，在某种意义上就是我衡量琐碎程度的标准。我觉得我热爱 C++ 和 Haskell 的地方，在 BQN 中应有尽有，甚至更多。欢迎来到 ADSP 播客第 215 期，录制于 2024 年 12 月 16 日。我是 Connor，今天和我的联合主持人 Ben 继续我们关于比较解决 Advent of Code 问题不同方法的第二部分讨论。在今天的讨论中，我们谈到了 C++、BQN 等。那么，这个观察背后的问题是：在你看来，BQN 是用来做什么的？它擅长什么？它能很好地解决什么问题？
And what is its typical application? I mean, I think BQN is amazing for everything. I understand you love array languages, but I hope you can see where I'm coming from. It's not great for memoization it's not great for when you have to put a big for loop and handle state in your code it doesn't seem naturally suited those things it seems great for reducing data structures summing them up you know scanning them doing all that stuff it seems algorithmically you can put all those things together really easily um but when it comes to some of this other stuff it it seems clunky i don't know i mean i the more i will say that
它的典型应用是什么？我的意思是，我认为 BQN 在各方面都很棒。我理解你热爱数组语言，但我希望你能明白我的意思。它不适合做记忆化，也不适合当你必须写一个大的 for 循环并处理代码中的状态时，它似乎并不自然地适合这些事情。它似乎非常适合简化数据结构、对它们求和、你知道的，扫描它们，做所有这些事情。在算法上，你可以很容易地把所有这些东西组合在一起。嗯，但当涉及到其他一些事情时，它似乎显得笨拙。我不知道，我的意思是，我会说
over the last year like one of my goals this year was to one of my criticisms on my youtube channel is that i just do one-liners which that's valid that's valid if you look at the corpus of code that i've written the majority of it is leet code, these small challenges, because that's fun. And with a limited set of knowledge, you can actually just go pretty far. actual language for writing substantial pieces of applications of software and now i've written you know all of these programs are you know 100 lines of code or less but that's still a dense amount of bqn code and so i've written a linter a formatter a unit tester all in bqn and the language definitely has its limitations there's no metaprogramming capabilities and so i do some hacky things to get like a pi test kind of unit testing framework i'm doing some things that are you know don't feel great coming from languages that have these
在过去的一年里，我今年的目标之一，也是对我 YouTube 频道的一个批评，就是我只写单行代码。这很合理，如果你看看我写过的代码库，大部分都是 LeetCode，这些小挑战，因为那很有趣。而且在有限的知识储备下，你确实可以走得很远。作为编写实质性软件应用程序的实际语言，现在我已经写了，你知道的，所有这些程序都是 100 行代码或更少，但这仍然是密集的 BQN 代码。所以我用 BQN 写了一个 linter、一个格式化程序、一个单元测试器。这门语言肯定有它的局限性，没有元编程能力，所以我做了一些黑客手段来获得类似 PyTest 的单元测试框架。我做的一些事情，你知道的，从那些拥有这些能力的语言转过来，感觉不太好。
these meta programming capabilities that being said it is it feels like the things that i love about c++ and haskell are just everything is there in bqN, like and more. And the way that I feel writing BQN code, it's just like, it's painful almost to go to any language now. In general, there are definitely things that other programming languages have that BQN doesn't, but I don't think it is a limitation of the array paradigm. It's just that bqn is not a language that has a metaprogramming facility you could design an array language that has one right it doesn't exist right now and it's in the back of your head thinking you know what are the small things that are missing that are made so much easier and i think metaprogramming is probably like the biggest one
这些元编程能力。话虽如此，我热爱 C++ 和 Haskell 的地方，在 BQN 中应有尽有，甚至更多。我写 BQN 代码的感觉，现在去用任何其他语言几乎都是一种痛苦。总的来说，其他编程语言肯定有 BQN 没有的东西，但我不认为这是数组范式的局限性。只是 BQN 不是一门拥有元编程设施的语言。你可以设计一门拥有这种设施的数组语言，对吧？它现在不存在。你脑子里会想，到底缺少了哪些让事情变得简单的小东西？我认为元编程可能是最重要的一点。
which is what led to your ability to do the decorator thing and memoizing functions in Python. Right, right. I mean, understand, I am not trying to level particular criticism at BQN. I'm not trying to do down BQN or APL or any other array language. I think I am coming, have come to recognize, like 40, 50 years ago, like if we wind the clock back, if we think about programming in the early 70s, mid 70s, even late 60s, in those days, there were hundreds of programming languages around, right? And they were, many of them were not what we would think of today as general purpose. They were designed for certain application scenarios. You know, you wouldn't use a numerical language for string processing and vice versa, for instance. Right. You had things like Fortran.
这正是你能够在 Python 中实现装饰器和记忆化函数的原因。对，对。我的意思是，请理解，我并不是要对 BQN 进行特别的批评。我不是要贬低 BQN、APL 或任何其他数组语言。我想我已经开始认识到，比如 40、50 年前，如果我们把时钟拨回，如果我们想想 70 年代初、70 年代中期，甚至 60 年代末的编程，在那个时代，周围有数百种编程语言，对吧？它们中许多并不是我们今天所认为的通用语言。它们是为特定的应用场景设计的。你知道，你不会用数值语言进行字符串处理，反之亦然。对吧。你有像 Fortran 这样的东西。
You had Snowball. You had, you know, literally hundreds of languages back um that many of which are now not in our consciousness anymore um you know we could name the half a dozen that have really survived but you know it's the same actually true today we don't tend to think that way today but but you know watching the things you do in bqn thinking about what's easy to do in python what's easy in haskell what's easy in C++. It seems to me like that might still be true today. Languages have
你有 SNOBOL。你有，你知道的，当时确实有数百种语言，其中许多现在已经不再存在于我们的意识中了。你知道，我们可以列举出真正幸存下来的那六七种，但你知道，今天的情况其实也是一样的。我们今天往往不这么想，但你知道，看着你在 BQN 中做的事情，思考在 Python 中什么容易做，在 Haskell 中什么容易做，在 C++ 中什么容易做。在我看来，这在今天可能仍然适用。语言有
a particular fit for application domains. Okay, yeah. So I get closer to... I mean, I still maintain that... I think I can't remember when or where on some recording somewhere, I said that BQN has been my favorite language for a while
特定的应用领域契合度。好的，是的。所以我更接近……我的意思是，我仍然坚持认为……我想我不记得是在什么时候或什么地方的录音里，我说过 BQN 已经是我最喜欢的语言有一段时间了。
but the the gap that it is putting on other languages is like ever increasing and a part of the reason uh paradoxically is because my discovery of like i always knew that there was a system while um loop or like while higher order function technically is what it is it's not really a loop um or i guess it's both. But I never used to use that. And that meant that like for certain tasks, it becomes difficult to do it in BQN without that kind of thing. But now that it's there. Right. And I know I can reach for it.
但它与其他语言之间的差距正在不断扩大。部分原因，矛盾的是，是因为我发现了……我一直知道有一个 while 循环，或者说从技术上讲它是一个高阶函数，它并不是真正的循环……或者我想它两者都是。但我以前从不使用它。这意味着对于某些任务，没有那种东西在 BQN 中就很难完成。但现在它有了。对。而且我知道我可以随时使用它。
Like there was a, I think one of the most recent problem that I did day 14. Part B is like find a Christmas tree in your input. And I'm like, what? What do you mean find a Christmas tree? It's just like it's like a grid. They give you no description of what it looks like or how to find it. And I made an educated guess and my educated guess. But basically, you just need to iterate on these little things moving around on your grid for this rules of like how these things move.
比如有一个，我想是我最近做的第 14 天的问题。B 部分是让你在输入中找到一棵圣诞树。我就想，什么？你是指找到一棵圣诞树？它就像一个网格。他们没有给你任何关于它看起来是什么样或如何找到它的描述。我做了一个有根据的猜测，我的猜测是……但基本上，你只需要在这些小东西在网格上移动时进行迭代，根据这些东西如何移动的规则。
And that at a certain point, it just materializes a little picture of a tree. And that is like it's exactly what you need a while loop for like you don't need a reduction or a scan you need something that iterates conditionally that's a while loop like and uh and now that it's there i find myself reaching for it probably more than i should because that's one of the criticisms a couple folks have made of the videos is that sometimes there is an array solution that I ignore because the more intuitive thing to do, or at least for my brain is to reach for this kind of conditional exit. I mean, it sounds like, it sounds like what we're agreeing on is that, you know, when you start out learning a language, particularly one like BQN or like Haskell,
在某个点上，它就会显现出一棵树的小图片。这正是你需要 while 循环的地方，你不需要归约或扫描，你需要的是能够有条件地迭代的东西，那就是 while 循环。而且现在它有了，我发现自己使用它的频率可能比我应该做的要高，因为这是几个人对视频提出的批评之一，有时有一个数组解决方案我却忽略了，因为对我大脑来说更直观的做法是使用这种条件退出。我的意思是，听起来我们达成一致的是，你知道，当你开始学习一门语言时，特别是像 BQN 或 Haskell 这样的语言，
the language and the paradigm are very closely knit, right? And what you just said to me indicates that, you know, you're now sort of discovering, well, of course you knew, but, you know, you're doing different paradigms in BQN other than the array paradigm, right? Because the paradigm fits the problem better. Yeah. And I think that's what i'm discovering is that there was this set of things that bqn is just lights out better than any other language and i think that's
语言和范式是紧密结合的，对吧？你刚才对我说的表明，你知道，你现在正在发现，好吧，当然你早就知道，但你知道，你正在 BQN 中使用除数组范式之外的其他范式，对吧？因为范式更适合这个问题。是的。我认为我正在发现的是，有一组事情是 BQN 比任何其他语言都要出色得多的，我认为这
probably what you're asking more but what i'm realizing is that like not only is it amazing at that stuff but it can still do the other stuff let's talk about day five the the print ordering ordering the pages for print day five I think it was day five. Yes. Day five gives you page ordering rules, which are ordered pairs. You get a bunch of pairs of pages where, and the rule is that the first one must come before the second one. And so that's part one of the input. And then the second part is a bunch of lists of page numbers. And for the part A, you just have to say, are these numbers correctly ordered according to the rules?
可能就是你问得更多的，但我意识到的是，它不仅在那些方面很棒，而且仍然可以做其他事情。让我们谈谈第五天，打印页面的排序，我想是第五天。是的。第五天给了你页面排序规则，它们是有序对。你得到了一堆页面对，规则是第一个必须在第二个之前。所以这是输入的第一部分。然后第二部分是一堆页面编号列表。对于 A 部分，你只需要说，这些数字是否根据规则正确排序了？
Mm-hmm. Right? So I look at this puzzle. So I say, I haven't solved this puzzle. I have not coded up the solution. But the way I would do it in C++ is to recognize that the first part of the input defines your sort function, right? And then you just say, is sorted according to that function. The first part of the input is basically you would make a multi-map or something. And from that multi-map, you'd be able to answer the question, given any two numbers, are those numbers ordered? Is A less than B? And then you
嗯哼。对吧？所以我看了这个谜题。我说，我还没解开这个谜题。我还没有写出解决方案。但我会在 C++ 中做的方法是认识到输入的第一部分定义了你的排序函数，对吧？然后你只需要说，是否根据该函数排序。输入的第一部分基本上你会做一个多重映射或类似的东西。从那个多重映射中，你将能够回答这个问题：给定任意两个数字，这些数字是否有序？A 小于 B 吗？然后你
would just call is sorted. And I think part two watched your video i've learned that part two you would call sort right according to the definition of the ordering which is given by the first part of the input so which is all to say that i think this problem in c++ is trivial or close to trivial it's like it's like you make a multi-map that is your sort function and then you call is sorted and then you call sort right there are only three ideas there and and the the the number of ideas in the problem is how i measure the triviality in the sentence i would well do i want to say disagree go ahead disagree with me my guess is that whatever the c++ code ends up looking like is is nothing compared to the elegance of what bqn gives you and bqn actually uh has a like i ended up once again looking at i think i solved it initially but then i ended up looking at other solutions like i always will try and
只需要调用 is sorted。我想第二部分看了你的视频，我了解到第二部分你会调用 sort，根据输入第一部分给出的排序定义。所以这一切都是说，我认为这个问题在 C++ 中是琐碎的或接近琐碎的。就像是，你制作一个多重映射作为你的排序函数，然后调用 is sorted，然后调用 sort，对吧？这里面只有三个想法。而问题中想法的数量就是我衡量琐碎程度的标准。我会……好吧，我想说不同意吗？继续，反驳我。我的猜测是，无论 C++ 代码最终看起来是什么样，都无法与 BQN 给你的优雅相比。而且 BQN 实际上……我最终又一次看了，我想我最初解决了它，但我最终看了其他解决方案，就像我总是会尝试的那样。
solve it myself and then i go and do like a code review because i think that's one of the best ways to learn is like sure you you might have solved it your way but seeing five or six other solutions from people that are experts in this language can lead you to some really nice things that you end up learning so i i do not doubt that the bqn solution is fewer characters by maybe one or two orders of magnitude right i'll give you two orders of magnitude on that one but i'm questioning like the the especially in a world perhaps where with an AI assistant in your editor, you can... My question to you is, is this changing things at all? If I could say to my editor, if the solution is...
自己解决它，然后我去进行代码审查，因为我认为这是学习的最佳方式之一。当然，你可能用你的方式解决了它，但看到来自这门语言专家的五六个其他解决方案，可以引导你学到一些非常好的东西。所以我并不怀疑 BQN 的解决方案字符数少了可能一两个数量级，对吧？我给你两个数量级。但我质疑的是，特别是在一个也许有 AI 助手在你的编辑器里的世界里，你可以……我的问题是，这有改变什么吗？如果我可以对我的编辑器说，如果解决方案是……
To me, I haven't coded up the problem, but we've just talked through a solution. And to code it up would be just a matter of hitting the keys in my head. And so, in a sense, it's as trivial to write that in C++ as it is in BQM, unless you can convince me otherwise. Well, actually, so let's take a step back, because I'm not sure I fully have comprehended, because I probably haven't actually, I've been too BQM-brained. When you say your multimap is your comparator, what do you actually mean by that? Do you have to, I assume you mean, you do not mean I can pass my multimap as a binary operation.
对我来说，我还没有写出这个问题，但我们刚刚讨论了一个解决方案。要写出来只需要在脑子里敲击键盘。所以，在某种意义上，用 C++ 写它和用 BQN 写它一样琐碎，除非你能说服我。好吧，实际上，让我们退一步，因为我不确定我是否完全理解了，因为我可能还没有……我太“BQN 脑”了。当你说是你的多重映射作为比较器时，你到底是什么意思？你必须……我假设你的意思是，你并不是说我可以把我的多重映射作为二元操作传递。
Like, do I have to wrap this in a lambda to some extent, correct? I need to write a less than function, right? I need to answer the question, is A less than B? That's what will power the sort or is sorted absolutely to answer is a less than b i can look up a in my multi-map and see if see if b is one of its values right that or vice versa right because, the way the input is structured. So I checked this. In the sample, seven numbers occur in the list of pages, right? 21 pairs are given.
比如，我是否必须在某种程度上把它包装在一个 lambda 里，对吧？我需要写一个小于函数，对吧？我需要回答这个问题：A 小于 B 吗？这就是驱动排序或 is sorted 的动力。绝对的，为了回答 A 是否小于 B，我可以在我的多重映射中查找 A，看看 B 是否是它的值之一，对吧？或者反之亦然，对吧？因为输入的结构方式。所以我检查了这个。在样本中，页面列表中出现了七个数字，对吧？给出了 21 对。
Yeah, it's complete. So seven choose two is 42, right? Seven ways to pick the first number, six ways to pick the remaining number. Half of 42 is 21 which is the number of rules we're given that is sufficient to determine because if you're given obviously a rule one way around it also applies the other way around for greater than so this was the question i had when i read through this is the input defining an order that we can use to power sort. And in fact, I believe it is. Yes. Because... Yeah.
是的，它是完整的。所以 7 取 2 是 42，对吧？选择第一个数字有 7 种方式，选择剩余数字有 6 种方式。42 的一半是 21，这就是我们给出的规则数量，这足以确定，因为如果你给出了一个方向的规则，它显然也适用于反方向的大于关系。所以这就是我读到这里时产生的问题：输入是否定义了一个我们可以用来驱动排序的顺序？事实上，我相信是的。是的。因为……是的。
So if I make that multi-map and I make it... Let's say I make it sort of both ways around, or my sort comparator looks both ways around, then that sort comparator is easy to write, right? I can answer the question, is A less than B, just by looking them up in the map. Okay. I fully understand now.
所以如果我制作那个多重映射，并且我让它……假设我让它双向排序，或者我的排序比较器看起来是双向的，那么那个排序比较器就很容易写了，对吧？我可以通过在映射中查找它们来回答 A 是否小于 B 的问题。好的。我现在完全明白了。
Yes. So there's several different ways you could do this. One of them, which would probably be the one that I would lean towards, is just, yeah, hand-rolling a lambda after populating this multi-map and then doing a call into that and you're done. Which is, I agree, quite simple. I mean, I don't want to get into the rich hickey complex versus complex etc etc but it's it's not a if you if you have in your tool
是的。所以你可以用几种不同的方式来做。其中一种，可能是我倾向于的那种，就是，是的，在填充这个多重映射后手动编写一个 lambda，然后调用它，你就完成了。我同意，这非常简单。我的意思是，我不想陷入 Rich Hickey 的复杂与简单等等，但如果你的工具带里有
belt the multi-map uh is sorted the algorithms the data structures and the mechanisms that are how to spell a lambda it's a pretty trivial thing you said, you don't actually need to go. The fact that we've just explained this in a couple of minutes, talking at the level of like, here's the algorithms, here's the structure, here's how you write the sort comparator done. That indicates to me that this is simple, as you say.
多重映射、is sorted、算法、数据结构以及如何拼写 lambda 的机制，这是一件非常琐碎的事情。你说过，你实际上不需要去……我们刚刚在几分钟内解释了这一点，谈论的层面是：这是算法，这是结构，这是你如何编写排序比较器，完成。这向我表明，正如你所说的，这很简单。
Yeah. So I still would, I still think that the BQN solution, not the one that I initially coded up, but the one that I ended up with, it is like a superpower level above the C++ one. And I also think that, and this is more of like a philosophical territory of like the elegance and the number of keystrokes to spell like that solution in C++ affects what does it affect obviously the elegance of the solution but i think it also affects my ability to go and play with the solution it's like i said like i i coded this up one way and then went and looked at other solutions and then immediately
是的。所以我仍然认为，BQN 的解决方案，不是我最初写的那个，而是我最终得到的那个，它比 C++ 的解决方案高出一个超能力级别。而且我也认为，这更多是关于优雅和拼写 C++ 解决方案所需的击键次数的哲学领域，它影响了什么？显然是解决方案的优雅程度，但我认为它也影响了我去尝试解决方案的能力。就像我说的，我用一种方式写了这个，然后去看了其他解决方案，然后立即
started like playing with my solution and modifying it the experience of doing that and this isn't to pick on c++ this is to pick on lots of languages it is sure it's almost like the it's it's that ability to play around with different solutions is non-existent like in a in a practical kind of like oh i'm doing this with an is sorted or assorted and now i gotta switch switch this out. I am just, maybe I'm not a good enough C++ developer, but I constantly am like spending time just trying to get the thing to compile versus like the malleability. And I think that's what's like,
开始摆弄我的解决方案并修改它。做这件事的体验，这并不是要挑剔 C++，这是要挑剔很多语言，它几乎就像是……那种摆弄不同解决方案的能力是不存在的。在实际操作中，比如“哦，我正在用 is sorted 或 sort 做这个，现在我得把它换掉”。我只是，也许我不是一个足够好的 C++ 开发人员，但我总是花时间试图让它编译通过，而不是那种可塑性。我认为这就是……
there's other people that do a way better job of articulating like the, like it's like the freedom, it's similar to if you've read SICP and then you get up to chapter five and you're building the circular evaluator interpreter or whatever the thing is called. Metacircular evaluator.
有其他人能更好地表达，比如，这就像自由，类似于如果你读过 SICP，然后你读到第五章，你在构建循环求值器解释器或者不管那东西叫什么。元循环求值器。
Metacircular. Yes. Thank you. Uh, it's like you, at that point you're like, wow, I just kind of wrote the whole language. Like you feel like empowered. You can write lisp in lisp in like 25 lines or something. And it gives you a sense of like, you know else can i do like i can now bend the i wrote the language i can do whatever i want with it i can go add my own constructs and i feel like c++
元循环。是的。谢谢。在那一点上，你会觉得，哇，我刚刚写了整个语言。你会感到被赋予了力量。你可以在 25 行左右用 Lisp 写 Lisp。它给了你一种感觉，你知道，我还能做什么？我现在可以弯曲……我写了这门语言，我可以随心所欲地处理它，我可以去添加我自己的结构。我觉得 C++
fights you when you try to do this versus like array languages and in these simpler languages like lisp and haskell i shouldn't call them simpler but just like the the fact that there's so much stuff that comes in the prelude with Haskell and there's not namespace and the text of double colons. And it's just like you can't that that one talk that I gave algorithms as a tool of thought, not notation as a tool of thought. Was that like I can go and write 11 solutions in a grand total of like 30 characters to this one problem all equal. And I can't even. Right. It's going to take me a couple minutes just to get something compiling. And it's probably not going to compile on the first time. Is to say that like, I think the C++ solution is elegant for what C++ can do.
在你尝试这样做时会与你作对，而像数组语言和这些更简单的语言（比如 Lisp 和 Haskell，我不应该称它们为更简单，但只是因为 Haskell 的 prelude 中有那么多东西，没有命名空间，还有双冒号的文本）。这就像你不能……我做的那次演讲，“算法作为思维工具，而不是符号作为思维工具”。就是说，我可以去写 11 个解决方案，总共只有 30 个字符，解决这一个问题，所有都相等。我甚至不能。对。我需要几分钟才能让它编译通过。而且它可能第一次还编译不过。这就是说，我认为 C++ 的解决方案对于 C++ 能做的事情来说是优雅的。
But like, it falls short of the power that you get with BQN. And the BQN solution, we haven't even talked about it. It uses this thing called like a table grade that when I saw it i was like oh my god that is that's like mind-blowing it's like these it's these things where you get the the uh uh inversion of uh indexes to get your histogram or you get these table grades it's like it's things that i don't i can't even begin to think like you would just you'd be hand rolling some bespoke thing in c++ anyways this is uh i feel like i'm picking on c++ is that it's fine i can i will defend it if you like i mean there's something in what you say i i accept that the there's something there which is the terseness of bqn uh does help your ability to very quickly play around with it right and like you say build a dozen solutions two dozen solutions in five ten
但它达不到你用 BQN 获得的那种力量。而 BQN 的解决方案，我们甚至还没谈到它。它使用了一种叫做“表等级”（table grade）的东西，当我看到它时，我就想，天哪，那真是令人大开眼界。它就像这些……它是这些东西，你得到索引的逆转来获得你的直方图，或者你得到这些表等级。这就像是一些我甚至无法想象的事情，你无论如何都会在 C++ 中手动编写一些定制的东西。总之，这……我觉得我在挑剔 C++，没关系，如果你愿意，我可以为它辩护。我的意思是，你说的话里有一些道理，我接受这一点，即 BQN 的简洁性确实有助于你非常快速地摆弄它，对吧？就像你说的，在五十分钟内构建一打解决方案、两打解决方案，
minutes and and try them all out um the question i have which i am unable to answer at the moment is like does having an llm assistant in your editor help with that in a language like c++ or python does does it narrow the playing field there i Python. Does it narrow the playing field there? I don't know. Does it narrow the playing field? That's a mixed metaphor. Does it narrow the gap? Does it level the playing field at all? I definitely think it does because whenever I program in Rust,
并尝试它们。我有一个目前无法回答的问题是：在编辑器中拥有一个 LLM 助手在像 C++ 或 Python 这样的语言中会有帮助吗？它会缩小那里的竞争环境吗？Python。它会缩小那里的竞争环境吗？我不知道。它会缩小竞争环境吗？这是一个混合隐喻。它会缩小差距吗？它会使竞争环境变得公平吗？我绝对认为它会，因为每当我用 Rust 编程时，
that is essentially what I'm doing. I'm asking an LLM, use iter tools. I want to fold a map, destructure this tuple. I can explain to it and it goes bum, bum, bum, bum, bum. And where I typically would hit a,
我本质上就是在做这件事。我问 LLM，使用 iter tools。我想折叠一个映射，解构这个元组。我可以向它解释，然后它就砰、砰、砰、砰、砰。而我通常会遇到一个
you need an unsigned I32 here, so you need an as, and you need a into iter instead of an iter here. All of those little bumps in the road, the LLM is going to nail because it's studied a corpus of correct Rust code out there. And me programming in Rust with an llm is like at least an order of magnitude if not more more productive right but the code that i still end up
你需要一个无符号 I32，所以你需要一个 as，你需要一个 into iter 而不是 iter。所有这些路上的小颠簸，LLM 都会搞定，因为它研究过现有的正确 Rust 代码库。而我用 LLM 编写 Rust 就像至少提高了一个数量级，如果不是更多的话，效率更高。但我最终得到的代码
with i am still like it doesn't doesn't touch doesn't touch the the nicety yeah the express the expressivity the terseness the just pure expression of the algorithmic ideas, I think. Yeah. And it's just like never in any language other than BQN, maybe Haskell a little bit. I'll run into like I wrote enumerate for all intents and purposes, which is, you know, just zipping with your corresponding index. Yeah. Yeah. It's called zip with index and
我仍然觉得它触及不到……触及不到那种美妙。是的，表达力、简洁性、对算法思想的纯粹表达，我认为是这样。是的，这就像在任何语言中，除了 BQN，也许还有一点 Haskell，我都会遇到……我写了 enumerate，出于所有实际目的，也就是，你知道，只是用你对应的索引进行 zip。是的。是的，它在 Scala 中叫 zip with index，
scala and it's called enumerate and python and i think it's in c++ 23 now yes fuse enumerate yeah yeah it's like four or five characters in bqn and i'm at the point where like i i saw it and i immediately read it understood it and was like wow this and it's tacit. It's a beautiful example of a tacit expression. Right. And it's half the length of the word. And like enumerate, maybe you can guess what that means if you've never seen it before. But like, it's not a bad name, but is it a name that like, I think zip with index, perfect name. You can, if you know what zip is, you can get your way to what zip with index is. But enumerate.
在 Python 中叫 enumerate，我想它现在在 C++ 23 中也有了，是的，fuse enumerate。是的，是的，它在 BQN 中只有四五个字符，我到了那种地步，我看到了它，我立即读懂了它，并想，哇，这个……而且它是隐式的（tacit）。这是一个隐式表达式的美丽例子。对。而且它只有那个词长度的一半。而且像 enumerate，也许如果你以前从未见过它，你可以猜出它的意思。但它不是一个坏名字，但它是一个名字，我想，我认为 zip with index 是完美的名字。你可以，如果你知道 zip 是什么，你就可以推导出 zip with index 是什么。但 enumerate。
I mean, if you know what enumerate is, same argument. But what you're saying, I think, is that you have cultivated algorithmic intuition, right? That is a big part of, you know, in the process of learning APL and BQN and the real languages in general, I think your ability to translate word problems into algorithms has grown tenfold. Right. And at some level, the problem of C++ is just that its affordances are so bad for that kind of thing. Yeah. Right. Everything in the standard is named after what it literally does, pretty much, not what you would typically want to use it for
我的意思是，如果你知道 enumerate 是什么，同样的论点。但你所说的是，我认为，你已经培养了算法直觉，对吧？这是学习 APL 和 BQN 以及通用数组语言过程中的很大一部分，我认为你将文字问题转化为算法的能力已经增长了十倍。对。在某种程度上，C++ 的问题仅仅是它的功能对于那种事情来说太糟糕了。对。标准中的一切都是以它字面上做什么来命名的，几乎都是这样，而不是你通常想要用它做什么。
yeah yeah right like last time we talked to when we talked to sean like the prosichal for me is always like rotate right you look at rotate and yeah it rotates blocks of things but you totally don't come away with the idea that the most common thing you're going to want to do 99% of the time is rotate a block of one thing and reposition one element in your sequence. And that's a rotate. Like it's named for the general thing it does and not for the common use cases. And that's bridging that gap is cultivating algorithmic intuition. Yeah.
是的，是的，对。就像上次我们和 Sean 交谈时，对我来说总是像 rotate right。你看看 rotate，是的，它旋转块状的东西，但你完全不会想到你 99% 的时间最常想做的事情是旋转一个东西的块，并重新定位序列中的一个元素。那是一个 rotate。它是以它所做的通用事情命名的，而不是为了常见的用例。而弥合那个差距就是培养算法直觉。是的。
And that gap doesn't really exist in BQN or applicative language where you just, you know, put these things together. Yeah, I think that's what you're nailing the nail on the head. That doesn't sound like it's right. But anyway, it's hitting the nail on the head. Hitting the nail. I was right. I was using both the nail as the verb and the noun.
而那个差距在 BQN 或应用语言中并不真正存在，在那里你只是，你知道，把这些东西放在一起。是的，我想你正中要害。这听起来不太对。但总之，是正中要害。正中要害。我是对的。我既把钉子当作动词，也当作名词使用。
Hitting the nail on the head in that. I don't know what the analogy is, it's like you know colored belts in in uh you know jujitsu or it's some religious like ascension up the ranks but like i started in like c++ algorithm land then like elevated to haskell where things were like cleaner and simpler but like you know this intuition you can build you know the exact same there and then i discovered apl and i feel like it's like the highest form of like if if you're on this like algorithm ascension path right you fall in love with this symbolic because and one of the talks that i'm planning on giving in 2025 is going to be called something like paradigms within paradigms and it's this realization
正中要害。我不知道这个类比是什么，就像你知道柔术中的色带，或者某种宗教般的晋升，但我开始是在 C++ 算法领域，然后提升到 Haskell，那里的事情更干净、更简单，但你知道，这种直觉你可以在那里建立，完全一样。然后我发现了 APL，我觉得它就像是最高形式的……如果你在这一条算法晋升之路上，对吧？你爱上了这种符号，因为……我计划在 2025 年做的一次演讲将被称为“范式中的范式”，这是这种认识：
that like inside of apl and bqn and these array languages is the out you can so beautifully develop the algorithm intuition but there are a number of other paradigms the array programming which is the rank polymorphism like the elision of having to spell map everything, map everywhere. But then there's also the combinator paradigm, which enables you to write this just absolutely beautiful tacit code, which it's so painful being in other languages, and not just like, you know, tacit expressions, like I want to use the S or the sigma combinator, but like things like partial application. I was just looking at some... Oh, that is, yeah, that's a game changer.
在 APL 和 BQN 以及这些数组语言中，你可以如此美妙地发展算法直觉。但还有许多其他范式。数组编程，也就是秩多态性（rank polymorphism），即省略了必须到处拼写 map 的需要。但还有组合子范式，它使你能够编写这种绝对美丽的隐式代码，在其他语言中感到非常痛苦。不仅仅是，你知道，隐式表达式，比如我想使用 S 或 sigma 组合子，而是像部分应用（partial application）这样的东西。我刚才在看一些……哦，那是，是的，那是改变游戏规则的东西。
Yeah. Someone that liked a tweet that I had tweeted from a year or two ago in 2022. And I was, it was me highlighting like, oh, if we got, if we got both destructuring in Lambda parameter lists and something else, We could have code that looked like this and the code still inside the body of the lambda was just doing return x equals equals one semicolon and I'm like, how am I advocating for like this is where we want to end up? Like that's just
是的。有人点赞了我一两年前在 2022 年发的一条推文。我当时是在强调，哦，如果我们既有 Lambda 参数列表中的解构，又有其他东西，我们就可以拥有看起来像这样的代码，而 Lambda 体内的代码只是在做 return x equals equals one 分号，我就想，我怎么在提倡这就是我们想要达到的目标？那只是
that's a partial application of a binary operation. It's equals one. Like in Haskell four characters. in most functional languages not four characters but it's still pretty short like and it's so fundamental it's so fundamental and so painful to do in a language like it's two characters whatever it's just they've got a just a partial application operator that on any binary operation, you just sit that in between whatever and the value you want to partially apply and stuff like that. Like, so it's what I think, you know, I get too excited about combinatory logic and like, you know, the D2 combinator that's like, or I see the delta combinator.
那是二元操作的部分应用。它是 equals one。就像 Haskell 中四个字符。在大多数函数式语言中不是四个字符，但它仍然很短。而且它太基础了，太基础了，在像……这样的语言中做起来太痛苦了。它只有两个字符，不管怎样，他们只是有一个部分应用运算符，在任何二元操作上，你只需要把它放在不管什么东西和你想要部分应用的值之间，诸如此类。所以这就是我认为，你知道，我对组合子逻辑太兴奋了，比如，你知道，D2 组合子，或者我看到 delta 组合子。
I was rewatching the CPP North. You spot a rare bird in the wild. Yeah. And I go nuts. It's exciting. People think it's like this esoteric thing that is like okay how useful is that what's really the useful stuff is the stuff that bores me because it's it's just happens all the time but that's the stuff that's super super useful um but then anyways back to
我正在重看 CPP North。你在野外发现了一只稀有鸟类。是的。我简直疯了。这很令人兴奋。人们认为这就像这种深奥的东西，就像“好吧，那有多大用处？”真正有用的东西是那些让我感到无聊的东西，因为它一直都在发生，但那些东西是非常非常有用的。但总之，回到
the paradigms on top of paradigms is that there's two other ones mask programming and then also under programming where it's like these things that you don't even have access to in other languages yeah mask programming is something i've noticed you talk about a lot of your solutions come down to that kind of thing where you make a mask you mentioned that a lot in your in your code report videos that is that is not a way that i typically think yet we might say yeah um it is very much on the on the level of whole meal programming transforming data structures by by by making masks and using them to select out whatever and then you know reducing and re-expanding and all that sort of thing and the the real moment when i
范式之上的范式，还有另外两个：掩码编程（mask programming）和 under 编程，这些东西你在其他语言中甚至无法接触到。是的，掩码编程是我注意到你经常谈论的，你的许多解决方案都归结为那种东西，你在代码报告视频中经常提到这一点。那不是我通常思考的方式，我们可能会说，是的。它非常处于“全餐编程”（whole meal programming）的水平，通过制作掩码并使用它们来选择出任何东西，然后你知道，归约和重新展开，所有这些事情。而当我真正意识到
realized that this is something that was like latent and i i wasn't acknowledging as like a whole way of programming was when i was building the the formatter and i was not making use of a use of a mask to split some stuff and so i was kind of using like a filter thing i was filtering out some unnecessary stuff. And for the simple case, that worked. But then when I wanted to do something more advanced that kind of relied on a couple criteria, that criteria depended on the structure of where things showed up. And after a single filter, you lose that structure.
这是一个潜伏的东西，而我没有承认它是一种完整的编程方式时，是我在构建格式化程序的时候。我没有使用掩码来分割一些东西，所以我有点像在使用 filter 东西，我在过滤掉一些不必要的东西。对于简单的情况，这有效。但当我想要做一些更高级的事情，依赖于几个标准时，那个标准取决于事物出现的位置结构。而在一次过滤之后，你就失去了那个结构。
And so I needed a way to basically apply like multiple filter operations, but like structure preserving filters. And that's what a mask is. It's just booleans, ones and zeros. And so as soon as I switched from splitting using like filtering, like in functional languages to splitting using masks, I can just stack those masks on top of each other, do a column wise reduction. And then poof, now I have my final mask that I want. And like how to solve that in a kind of functional style where you're just making use of the filter. It's like it kind of falls apart because now instead of filtering, I'm doing something with a scan and multiple scans and a scan is not really what I want. I just want to do this kind of mask based splitting or mask based filtering.
所以我需要一种方法来基本上应用像多次过滤操作，但像结构保留过滤器。而这就是掩码。它只是布尔值，一和零。所以一旦我从使用 filter（像在函数式语言中那样）分割切换到使用掩码分割，我就可以把这些掩码堆叠在一起，进行列向归约。然后砰，现在我有我想要的最终掩码了。而如何以一种函数式风格解决这个问题，即你只是使用 filter？它有点分崩离析，因为现在我不是在过滤，我是在用 scan 和多次 scan 做一些事情，而 scan 并不是我真正想要的。我只是想做这种基于掩码的分割或基于掩码的过滤。
And and yeah, anyways, I it's having more tools in the toolbox right? And sometimes having an entirely new toolbox you didn't know existed Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSPthePodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode as well as a link to a GitHub discussion
是的，总之，这是工具箱里有更多的工具，对吧？有时拥有一个你以前不知道存在的全新工具箱。请务必查看这些节目笔记，无论是在你的播客应用程序中还是在 ADSPthePodcast.com 上，获取我们今天提到的任何内容的链接，以及指向 GitHub 讨论的链接，
where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions Thanks for listening, we hope you enjoyed, and have a great day I am the anti-brace Um There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听，希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。我是反括号派。嗯，这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。